Marcel Proust was an early 20th century
French writer responsible for what's
officially the longest novel in the
world a la Hache
do Tampere Jew which has 1.2 million
words in it double those in war and
peace the book was published in French
in seven volumes over 14 years and was
immediately recognized to be a
masterpiece ranked by many as the
greatest novel of the century or simply
of all time what makes it so special is
that it isn't just the novel in a
straight narrative sense it's a work
that intersperses genius-level
descriptions of people and places with a
whole philosophy of life the clue is in
the title in search of lost time the
book tells the story of one man a thinly
disguised version of Proust himself in
his ongoing search for the meaning and
purpose of life
it recounts his quest to stop wasting
time and to start to appreciate
existence
Marcel Proust wanted his book to help us
above all his father at Yale Proust had
been one of the great doctors of his age
responsible for wiping out cholera in
France towards the end of his life his
frail indolent son Marcel who'd lived on
his inheritance and had disappointed his
family by never taking up a regular job
told his housekeeper Celeste
if only I could do humanity is much good
with my books as my father did with his
work the good news is that he amply
succeeded Proust novel charts the
narrator's systematic explorations of
three possible sources of the meaning of
life
the first is social success Proust was
born into a comfortable bourgeois
household but from his teens he began to
think that the meaning of life might lie
in joining high society which in his day
meant the world of aristocrats Dukes
Duchess and princes but if you convert
this to the present day
that would mean celebrities for years
the narrator devotes his energies to
working his way up the social hierarchy
and because he's charming and erudite he
eventually becomes friends with the
linchpins of Parisian high society that
you can do chess do get amant but a
troubling realization soon dawns on him
these people
watch the extraordinary Paragons he
imagined they would be the Dukes
conversation is boring and crass the
douche s though well-mannered is cruel
and vain must sell tires of thurman of
their circle he realizes that virtues
and vices are scattered throughout the
population without regard to income or
renown he grows free to devote himself
to a wider range of people though proof
spends many pages lampooning social
snobbery it's in a spirit of
understanding and underlying sympathy
it's a highly natural error especially
when one's young to suspect that there
might be a class of superior people
somewhere out there in the world and
that our lives might be dull principally
because we don't have the right contacts
but Proust novel offers us definitive
reassurance life is not going on
elsewhere there is no party where the
perfect people are the second thing the
proofs narrator investigates in his
quest for the meaning of life is love in
the second volume of the novel the
narrator goes off to the seaside with
his grandmother to the vogue --is--
resort of Kabul of the Barbados of the
times there he develops an overwhelming
crush on a beautiful teenage girl called
albertine she has short hair a boyish
smile and a charming casual way of
speaking for about 300 pages all the
narrator can think about is albertine
the meaning of life surely must lie in
loving her but with time here too
there's disappointment the moment comes
when the narrator is finally allowed to
kiss albertine man a creature clearly
less rudimentary than the sea urchin or
even the whale nevertheless lacks a
certain number of essential organs and
particularly possesses none that will
serve for kissing for this absent organ
he substitutes his lips and perhaps he
thereby achieves a results slightly more
satisfying than caressing his beloved
with a horny tusk the ultimate promise
of love in Proust eyes is that we can
stop being alone and properly fuse our
life with that of another person who
will understand every part of us but the
novel comes to darker conclusions no one
can fully understand
anyone loneliness is endemic we're
awkwardly lonely pilgrims trying to give
each other
tusks kisses in the dark this brings us
to the third and only successful
candidate for the meaning of life art
for Proust the great artists deserve a
claim because they show us the world in
a way that's fresh appreciative and
alive now the opposite of art for Proust
is something he calls habit for Proust
much of life is ruined for us by a
blanket or shroud of familiarity that
descends between us and everything that
matters habit dulls our senses and stops
us appreciating everything from the
beauty of sunsets to our work and our
friends children don't suffer from habit
which is why they get excited by some
very key but simple things like puddles
or jumping on the bed
sand or fresh bread but we adults get
spoiled about everything which is why we
seek ever more powerful stimulants like
the aforementioned Fame and love the
trick in proof size is to recover the
powers of appreciation of a child in
adulthood to strip the veil of habit and
therefore to start to appreciate daily
life with a new sensitivity this for
Proust is what one group in the
population does all the time artists
artists are people who know how to strip
habit away and return life to its true
deserved glory for example when they
show us water lilies or service stations
or buildings in a new light Bruce's goal
isn't that we should necessarily make
art or be someone who hangs out in
museums all the time the idea is to get
us to look at the world our world with
some of the same generosity as an artist
which would mean taking pleasure in
simple things like water the sky a shaft
of light on a piece of paper it's no
coincidence that Proust favorite painter
was Vermeer a painter who knew how to
bring out the charm and the value of the
everyday the spirit of Vermeer hangs
over his novel it too is committed to
the project of reconciling us to the
ordinary circumstances of life and some
of proofs moe
compelling pieces of writing describe
the charm of the everyday like reading
in a train driving at night smelling the
flowers in springtime and looking at the
changing light of the Sun on the sea
preusse is famous for having written
about the dainty little cakes the French
call Madeline the reason has to do with
his thesis about art and habit early on
in the novel the narrator tells us that
he'd been feeling depressed and sad for
a long while when one day he had a cup
of herbal tea and a Madeleine and
suddenly the taste carried him
powerfully back in the way that flavors
sometimes can two years in his childhood
when as a small boy he spent his summers
in his aunt's house in the French
countryside a stream of memories comes
back to him and fills him with hope and
gratitude thanks to the Madeleine Proust
narrator has what has since become known
as a pristine moment a moment of sudden
involuntary and intense remembering when
the past promptly emerges unbidden from
a smell taste or a texture through its
rich evocative power what the pristine
moment teaches us is that life isn't
necessarily dull and without excitement
it's just one forgets to look at it in
the right way we forget what being alive
fully alive actually feels like the
moment with the tea is pivotal in the
novel because it demonstrates everything
that Proust wants to teach us about
appreciating life with greater intensity
it helps his narrator to realize that it
isn't his life which has been mediocre
so much as the image of it he possessed
in normal that is voluntary memory
Proust writes the reason why life may be
judged to be trivial although at certain
moments it seems to us so beautiful is
that we form our judgment ordinarily not
on the evidence of life itself but of
those quite different images which
preserve nothing of life and therefore
we judge it disparagingly that's why
artists are so important their work is
like one long pristine moment they
remind us that life truly is beautiful
fascinating and complex and thereby
there dispel our boredom and our
ingratitude
Prue's philosophy of art is delivered in
a book which is itself exemplary of what
he's saying it's a work of art that
brings the beauty and interest of the
world back to life reading it your
senses are reawakened a thousand things
you normally forget to notice are
brought to your attention he makes you
for a time as clever and as sensitive as
he was and for this reason alone we
should be sure to read him and the 1.2
million words he assembled for us and
thereby learn to appreciate existence
before it's too late
you